un sobrevuelo por las montañas mexicanas
de Guerrero en busca de cultivos de Coca
los carteles mexicanos ahora la siembran
para adaptarse al millonario negocio del
tráfico de drogas es una actividad que
no había sido detectada anteriormente Y
bueno ya este como les mencioné en un
mes y medio llevamos de este durante el
2023 llevamos 27 plantillas localizados
durante años Los Campesinos de este
estado sembraron marihuana y Amapola
materia prima de la heroína pero cambió
el consumo en Estados Unidos hacia el
fentanilo estas drogas sintéticas 50
veces más poderosa que la heroína es
mucho más Adictiva y potencialmente
mortal ahora los cultivadores y los
narcotraficantes se decantan por la hoja
de coca con la que se produce cocaína
los grupos de la delincuencia organizada
tratan de obtener diversificar sus
actividades y Bueno yo creo que es una
experimentación de
del planteo de Coca la producción de
esta droga se Bolivia Perú y Colombia en
este último país se producen dos tercios
de la cocaína del mundo fueron unas 2000
toneladas en 2021 los carteles mexicanos
controlan casi toda la distribución de
este estupefaciente que proviene de
Colombia según inside Prime aunque han
extendido su producción a Honduras y
Guatemala países que hasta hace poco
eran utilizados solo para el tránsito de
las drogas frente a estos nuevos
cultivos en México se han erradicado
unos 360.000 metros cuadrados en los
últimos cuatro años la cocaína Aún es de
las drogas más rentables del mundo el
precio del kilo puede ser de más de mil
dólares en el país de origen mientras en
Europa puede costar 38 mil dólares